carrusel de las artes maría carolina
piña
[Música]
les damos la bienvenida a este programa
especial desde el arco del triunfo uno
de los monumentos más conocidos de la
capital francesa y cuya construcción fue
decidida por napoleón y de hecho será
buena parte el hilo conductor de este
carrusel de las artes en el marco del
bicentenario de su muerte
en este programa recorreremos parís tras
las huellas de napoleón bonaparte
todavía hoy la capital francesa hace
alarde de numerosas obras a la gloria de
quien se autoproclamó emperador de los
franceses como conmemorar a una figura
controvertida como es bonaparte que
hicimos la pregunta al director de la
fundación napoleón de ágil leds e iremos
también al museo de la legión de honor
una condecoración y tradición creada por
napoleón en 1804 y que se sigue
entregando a uno
[Música]
comenzamos este recorrido por el parís
de napoleón en un punto neurálgico de la
capital francesa el arco del triunfo una
obra monumental son casi 50 metros de
altura y colocado en una rotonda desde
donde salen 12 avenidas de la capital
francesa y para hablarnos de este
monumento tenemos cita con alguien que
trabaja aquí
autonation inc buenos días santo en un
burro otro y nos puede explicar un poco
la historia de este monumento que está
aquí en parís es uno de los monumentos
más visitados de la capital francesa y
fue una de las obras que napoleón
encargó para la capital cuesta más y fue
un monumento solicitado por napoleón
tras su victoria en la batalla de
austerlitz en diciembre de 2.805 es una
obra que según la leyenda fue dedicada a
los soldados del gran ejército de
napoleón se dice que napoleón habría
prometido a sus soldados que regresarían
a parís bajo arcos de triunfo es una
leyenda pero en todo caso la
construcción del monumento se decidió
por decreto imperial en febrero de 1806
y se tardaron 30 años en construirlo de
hecho
napoleón nunca
terminado porque cuando dejó el poder
apenas se habían construido 20 metros y
ahora estamos justo al lado de una de
estas obras la estética del arco de
triunfo es estética romana y napoleón
que está representado aquí en forma de
emperador háblenos de este relieve bueno
todas las esculturas del arco del
triunfo fueron ejecutadas entre 1833 y
1836 durante la monarquía de julio según
el deseo del rey luis felipe la
dedicatoria del monumento preveía un
homenaje a los ejércitos de la
revolución y del imperio por eso en el
pilar sureste encontramos un grupo
escultórico llamado el triunfo que
representa el año 1810 es decir el
apogeo de napoleón
allí napoleón primero está representado
como un emperador romano vestido con una
túnica y una corona de laurel y rodeado
de varios personajes que exaltan su
figura una mujer de rodillas y con
corona en forma de muralla que
representa las ciudades conquistadas la
musa de la historia club escribe las
grandes victorias de bonaparte
dos deidades alegóricas una que lo
corona y otra que toca una trompeta y
que recuerda las victorias de napoleón
este arco del triunfo de napoleón a
seguir triunfando durante más de 200
años es uno de los monumentos más
visitados de la capital francesa
el triunfo es visitado por más de un
millón seiscientos mil personas al año
al menos antes de la pandemia es uno de
los monumentos más visitados de parís
uno de los más apreciados y escenario de
muchos eventos populares muchas gracias
napoleón sigue fascinando a los
historiadores desde su muerte se han
escrito más de 110 mil libros sobre él
otros lo ven como una figura
controvertida de la historia le reclaman
su personalidad autoritaria su sed de
conquista y decisiones como el
restablecimiento de la esclavitud en
francia así que fuimos al encuentro del
historiador de agilent le preguntamos si
se debe o no conmemorar a napoleón en el
siglo 21
[Música]
para conmemorar es distinto de celebrar
a poner es un personaje central de la
historia de francia y lo que se debe
hacer es recordar lo que fue su gobierno
así que en el bicentenario de su muerte
habrá muchos coloquios de conferencias
programas de televisión radio y
numerosas exposiciones para que cada
quien se haga su propia idea de lo que
ha sido la historia no se trata de una
conmemoración hermética al contrario
todos los temas serán abordados
la francia de hoy está muy marcada por
el gobierno a poleo niko muchas
instituciones francesas fueron creadas
durante el consulado y el imperio
napoleón jugó un papel muy importante en
el urbanismo muchos monumentos y reglas
urbanas fueron decididas por él como la
numeración de las viviendas y las calles
y la obligación de barrer frente a su
puerta pero además de eso cada ciudadano
francés lleva napoleón en su vida
cotidiana nuestro código civil fue
adoptado durante su gobierno y aunque se
ha modificado y modernizado la esencia
de la misma así que podríamos decir que
el napoleón está en
otros y que quizás sin saberlo su legado
está presente en nuestra vida diaria
nos hemos subido ahora al techo del arco
del triunfo para hablarles de la legión
de honor la condecoración más
prestigiosa que tiene francia y que fue
creada por napoleón melissa barra fue al
museo de la legión de honor de parís
[Música]
el museo de la legión de honor en el
corazón de parís abarca 200 años de
historia a través de la distinción más
importante en francia creada en 1802
[Música]
con
buena parte se dio cuenta de que los
ciudadanos no necesitaban ser alentados
y que la nación necesitaba una élite
visible que sirviera de modelo en europa
otros sistemas distinguían a los
funcionarios con rangos de nobleza y con
decoraban a los soldados pero la
modernidad de la legión de honor yace en
su universalidad no se hace distinción
entre los méritos y miles y la valentía
militar porque todos están al servicio
de una misma nación
son potencias de la nación que tienen
[Música]
cuando se creó la insignia se escogió
una estrella con puntas vividas como la
cruz de malta pero se le agregó a una
quinta punta para volverla laica en una
cara tiene la figura del emperador y en
el reverso un águila imperial' el
símbolo heráldico que napoleón escogió
para su imperio bajo la restauración
borbónica se puso al rey enrique cuarto
y una flor de lis y desde que se
instauró la república vemos un perfil de
la diosa ceres efigie de la república y
detrás las banderas entre cruzadas la
estrella está rodeada de una corona de
hojas de roble y de laurel que
representan los méritos su vil y
militares por el emérito civil y militar
[Música]
la legión de honor se abarca un gran
abanico de profesiones y sectores del
país
el criterio es haber servido a la nación
durante 20 años o destacarse por un acto
espectacular
fue recompensado por ejemplo louis
pasteur a finales del siglo 19
últimamente fueron distinguidos
profesionales del sector salud que
luchan en primera línea contra la
pandemia de lakovic hay astronautas
también como toma pesqué quien fue
nombrado caballero tras su primera
expedición y extranjeros como el autor
gabriel garcía márquez o rigoberta
menchú quien recibió la legión de honor
por su defensa de los derechos humanos y
duatlón
hoy en día viven en francia y en el
mundo más de 90.000 legionarios
napoleón primero murió el 5 de mayo de
1821 en el exilio en la isla santa elena
19 años después el rey luis felipe
decidió repatriar sus restos a parís y
colocarlos debajo del domo del hotel de
los inválidos los invito a descubrir
este monumento excepcional en el corazón
de la capital francesa
el inmenso sarcófago de napoleón
bonaparte se encuentra en una cripta
circular de 6 metros de profundidad y 23
metros de ancho rodeada de dos estatuas
femeninas de mármol blanco llamadas las
victorias
tenemos cita aquí en la sala de la tumba
de napoleón con la conservadora en jefe
silva jamie muchísimas gracias por
recibirnos en esta sala de la tumba de
napoleón cuéntenos cómo fue posible que
después de haber sido desterrado de
francia napoleón se encuentre aquí quien
decidió colocar sus restos en esta sala
son dos veces el retorno de los restos
fue pedido por el rey luis felipe y fue
él mismo quien pidió colocarlos aquí era
un monarca liberal y moderado con la
repatriación de los restos luis felipe
quería rehabilitar a napoleón en la
historia de francia fue una decisión que
rompió completamente con la postura de
sus predecesores los borbones
louis 18 y carlos décimo quienes habían
censurado a napoleón luís felipe quiso
considerarlo como uno de los soberanos
más importantes que ha tenido francia
eso explica la elección del hotel de los
inválidos institución fundada por
14 el rey sol para colocar los restos de
napoleón jugaba y se lo tumbó toronja y
ahora bien no vemos un solo sarcófago
sino 5 cuéntenos un poco este monumento
se tom waits mundo estás callejón wow
carácter estos sarcófagos que están unos
dentro de otros recuerdan el carácter
casi sagrado que se asoció a los restos
del emperador
efectivamente el cuerpo de bonaparte
reposa en un sarcófago colocado en otro
y en otro cuatro de los cinco sarcófagos
vienen de la isla santa elena el quinto
es de ébano y fue fabricado en parís el
conjunto se encuentra en una escultura
visible hecha con cuarcita roja una
piedra que evoca la eternidad y la
grandeza de los imperios griegos y
romanos el arquitecto joaquín visconti
cubrió el interior de este último
sarcófago de cuarcita roja con mármol de
la isla de córcega donde nació napoleón
y una última pregunta sobre el monumento
porque el sarcófago está rodeado de
estas dos estatuas llamadas las
victorias pero también se recuerda en
este monumento las acciones políticas de
napoleón
de julio un sueño aunque los restos de
napoleón están en este hotel de los
inválidos que es una institución militar
esta cripta recuerda sobre todo su obra
civil y política se ponen de relieve las
acciones de napoleón que fundaron la
nación francesa el código civil la
universidad imperial el código mercantil
la legión de honor la pacificación de la
nación el concordato todas esas obras se
evocan en esta sala
siete hits con louis philippe
atornillamiento con una versión
aquí ponemos punto final este programa
especial en el que recorrimos parís para
recordar a napoleón bonaparte el primer
emperador de los franceses es en este
patio de honor del hotel de los
inválidos y bajo la mirada de buena
parte que les damos las gracias por su
amable sintonía nací boku agua
y
mira